außerirdisches leben ist auf mehr
exoplaneten möglich als bisher gedacht
exoplaneten sind höchstwahrscheinlich
die brutstätten für außerirdisches leben
doch was ist wenn ihr zentralgestirn ein
roter zwerg ist welche gefahr geht von
den extremen strahlungs ausbrüchen ihrer
sterne aus schädigen die superflex die
bewohnbarkeit der exoplaneten eine
aktuelle studie kommt jetzt zu einem
absolut überraschenden ergebnis dass man
wieder alles auf den kopf stellt dabei
ist das prinzip dahinter eigentlich ganz
simple tricks und stunts in future hier
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los ging's
herzlich willkommen
außerirdisches leben wo hält es sich
versteckt allein in unserer milchstraße
könnten schätzung zur folge achtung
10.000 außerirdische zivilisationen
existieren doch wo sind sie das umfeld
der sogenannten roten zwerge wurde in
der vergangenheit bei unserer suche nach
außerirdischem leben eher links liegen
gelassen der grund die heftigen
strahlungs ausbrüche auch superflex
genannt rote zwerge sind bekannt für
ihre aktivität und extremen ausbrüche
die außerirdisches leben verhindern oder
gefährden könnten doch um diese roten
zwerge herum wurden in der vergangenheit
zahlreiche exoplaneten entdeckt dabei
auch er tätige planeten die ihren stern
innerhalb dessen lebens front reaktionen
umkreisen unter fachleuten auch als
sogenannten habitablen zone bezeichnet
gemeint ist damit die abstands region in
der ein planet einen stern umkreisen
muss damit gemäßigte temperatur
möglicherweise die existenz von
flüssigem wasser erlauben denn das gilt
zumindest bei dem leben das wir auf der
erde kennen als grundvoraussetzung dafür
dass leben existieren kann doch
verhindern die häufigen und intensiven
strahlungs ausbrüche möglicherweise dass
sich hier im umfeld der roten zwerge
außerirdisches leben entwickeln kann ein
internationales forschungsteam hat jetzt
endlich das große rätsel gelöst ob diese
flairs die habit abily tape und
atmosphäre von exoplaneten nachhaltig
schädigen können konnte dieser verdacht
also bestätigt werden ehrlich ich würde
mich nicht mit dem thema beschäftigen
wenn es hier nicht spektakuläre
neuigkeiten gäbe schätzungen zufolge
sind drei viertel aller sterne rote
zwerge auch bei der großen mehrheit
aller sterne in unserer kosmischen
nachbarschaft handelt es sich um
sogenannte rote zwerge der wohl
bekannteste ist proxima centauri der uns
abgesehen von der sonne so nahe ist wie
kein anderer stern er ist nur 4,2
lichtjahre von uns entfernt rote zwerge
weisen nur etwa 1 bis 7 zehntel der
sonnenmasse auf und so läuft die
kernfusion im inneren der roten zwerge
eher auf sparflamme heißt also im
klartext gute sterne produzieren wenig
energie ihre oberflächen temperaturen
liegen bei 2400 bis 2700 kelvin das
entspricht in etwa der temperatur des
kühlwassers einer vintage glühlampe
heißt also es handelt sich um ziemliche
funzeln und selbst unser nachbar stern
proxima centauri ist so lichtschwach
dass wir ihn trotz seiner nähe mit
bloßem auge nicht erkennen können doch
auch er hat einen planeten in der
habitablen zone so auch trapp ist eins
der insgesamt über sieben planeten
verfügt von denen schätzungen zufolge
zwei bis vier in der habitablen zone
liegen aussichtsreiche kandidatin bei
unserer suche nach außerirdischem leben
also wenn da nicht diese extremen
strahlungs ausbrüche werden kann sich
leben bei solchen bedingungen überhaupt
entwickeln und könnte potenzielles
außerirdisches leben die auswirkungen
solcher super flyers überstehen denn das
wissen fachleute schon seit längerer
zeit rote zwerge weisen trotz der
geringen energie eine extrem hohe solare
aktivität auf die zu einer starken
strahlungsbelastung für die rede ist von
der so genannten flash aktivität dieser
sterne das internationale forschungsteam
beschreibt das so diese sogenannten
flyers sind magnetische explosion in der
atmosphäre von sternen die intensive
elektromagnetische strahlung in den
weltraum schleudern große flyers sind
mit der aussendung von energiereichen
teilchen verbunden die exoplaneten um
den ausbrechenden stern treffen und
deren atmosphäre verändern oder sogar
zerstören können diese flairs meinen
also grob gesagt aktivitäten auf der
oberfläche die von der so genannten
connect even schicht herrühren
elektrisch leid das glas markt bewegt
sich und erzeugt elektrische ströme die
dann wiederum zum magnetfeldern führen
sobald eine magnetische zone instabil
wird wird die im magnetfeld gespeicherte
energie schlagartig frei und das führt
zu einem auswurf von plasma in den
weltraum flairs produzieren also riesige
mengen an extremer von röntgenstrahlung
solche flairs gibt es bei manchen roten
zwergen alle paar jahre die meist noten
zwergsterne aber sind sehr aktiv
deutlich aktiver als sonnenähnliche
sterne und das hat konsequenzen für die
umliegenden planeten die sehr oft mit
einer hoch energetischen strahlung
geflutet werden und diese strahlung ist
extrem sie ist nicht nur in der lage
vorhandene atmosphären zu zerstören auch
die dann völlig ungeschützten
oberflächen dieser planeten könnten
durch sie angegriffen werden könnten
fachleute haben in der vergangenheit
darüber gerät sind inwieweit die
energiereichen teilchen die atmosphären
von exoplaneten verändern oder sogar
zerstören können erst anfang des jahres
hatten wir hier bei pixum sind future
über eine spannende studie in diesem
zusammenhang berichtet dass videos am
ende des videos hier verlinkt in
simulationen hatten forschen analysiert
wie sich solche flairs auf die
atmosphärenchemie vom planeten innerhalb
der habitablen zone auswirken demnach
ist solch ein extremes weltraumwetter
nicht unbedingt das zwangsläufige aus
für die entstehung in der entwicklung
von leben das fazit des forschungsteams
lautete tatsächlich können gerade auch
fortwährende flairs eines sterns die
atmosphärische zusammensetzung eines
planeten in ein neues gleichgewicht
bringen aus diesem grund schließen sie
den lahrer ausbrüche auch nicht per se
die existenz von leben auf dortigen
planeten aus in einigen fällen führen
selbst stetige fluss nicht dazu etwa die
gesamte planetare ozonschicht aufzulösen
leben auf dortigen oberflächen hätte
also weiterhin eine chance und nicht nur
das das us forschungsteam kam weiterhin
zu dem ergebnis dass fler sogar
hilfreich für unsere suche nach
außerirdischen lebens sein könnten denn
sie könnten es erleichtern dieses leben
aufzuspüren und zu detektieren dieses
weltraumwetter könnte also sogar dazu
beitragen dass forschungsteams weltweit
die signaturen von chemischen biomarkern
auf einem planeten besser identifizieren
könnten und die aktuelle studie eines
internationalen forschungsteams kommt zu
einem absolut spektakulären ergebnis das
alles auf den kopf stellt mit der hilfe
des tren sitting exoplanet server
satellite tests haben die astronomen
astronomen große superflex auf roten
zwergen genauer ins visier genommen und
so wurde klar dass diese ausbrüche nur
begrenzt oder anfang gar nicht
gefährlich für planetensysteme sind wie
bitte wie kann das sein die begründung
dafür die superflat explodieren nicht in
richtung der exoplaneten die astronomen
katharina in den vom leibniz institut
für astrophysik potsdam hat dafür eine
methode entwickelt um genau zu verstehen
von wo auf der oberfläche der roten
zwerge die flyers entspringen und so
gelangt die überraschende erkenntnis
dazu sagt sie wie entdeckten das extrem
große flairs in der nähe der pole von
roten zwergen zünden und nicht an ihrem
äquator wie es bei der sonne
typischerweise der fall ist exoplaneten
die sich auf einer bahn in der ebene um
den äquator des sterns bewegen sowie die
planeten in unserem eigenen sonnensystem
könnten daher weitgehend vor solchen
superflex geschützt sein da diese nach
oben oder unten aus dem exoplaneten
system heraus gerichtet sind die analyse
war sehr aufwändig denn die fachleute
mussten sich durch das archiv der test
beobachtungen arbeiten hier hielten sie
ausschau nach sternen die große flairs
aufweisen dafür werteten sie insgesamt
die licht kurven von mehr als 3.000
roten zwergen aus insgesamt über 400
jahren beobachtungszeit entspricht
insgesamt vier sterne eigneten sich um
die neu entwickelte methode anzuwenden
und bei allen vier analysen zeigte sich
dass die fans viel näher am pol
auftreten als bislang vermutet viel
näher am pol außerdem auch als die
eruption unserer sonne dem
forschungsteam gelang es sogar die
existenz sogenannter polarer flecken
nachzuweisen mit der hilfe von
indirekten techniken wurden diese polen
flecken bereits in der vergangenheit
aufgespürt doch jetzt erst gelang der
erste direkte nachweis diese polaren
flecken entstehen wenn sich in der nähe
der rotation pole von schnell
rotierenden sternen starke und
dynamische
konzentrationslager magnetfelder bilden
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam ich
freue mich besonders dass wir die
existenz der polaren flecken bei solch
schnell rotierenden sternen endlich gut
belegen können in der zukunft wird uns
dies helfen die magnetfeld strukturen
dieser wir haben besser zu verstehen die
aktuelle studie zeigt also dass extreme
strahlungs ausbrüche bevorzugt in hohen
breitengraden auftreten planeten die um
den stern äquator kreisen und auf denen
sich möglicherweise außerirdisches leben
versteckt hält werden dabei einfach
verschont
aliens in der nachbarschaft so nah
könnte die nächste zivilisation seinen
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann klettern